this video was made possible with the
help of Nord VPN more about them at the
end in this video so you're the health
of the u.s. you've grown comfortable
with being the world leader for so long
now that you view the US as untouchable
now unlike every other empire in the
past the US Empire will never fail don't
be silly but then comes along these
arrogant Chinese out of nowhere in a
single generation these foreigners went
from being nobodies to riesen to the top
of the global stage near us their people
are getting richer they're starting to
pass us on all sorts of economic
indicators they have so much more power
and control over their populace compared
to us that's almost unfair in fact no
other country has ever risen so far so
fast on so many dimensions of power that
it's starting to make us feel rather
insecure they're out shunning the master
the biggest threat to America is not
al-qaeda it's not Isis it's not Putin
it's not any of these guys it's China
you really believe that I believe it I
think it's the most consequential
existential threat not just to America
just to democracy the world's ever seen
worse yet you're well aware of what's
called Thucydides trap where in the last
500 years whenever there was a rising
power threatening a ruling power it
ended in bloodshed 12 out of 16 times
now besides the people who profit from
work no one really wants to go to war
it's such a hassle
China is even outright said hey what a
win a conventional war with the US but
the history is there and China has its
eyes set on our throne we have to be
prepared for anything including all-out
war with China within the next decade
now the naive out there will say that
war with China is inconceivable quite
fear-mongering and yet the most
impactful events in history are often
the most unimaginable ones the ones
we're leading up to where people said
that that would never happen stop being
paranoid
and yet our history books are just a
series of wars and the shifting power
that followed along with a few nice
things that happened here
their war is our nature so in times like
this in the name of preparedness
Murphy's Law just as a thought
experiment let's say we need to go to
war with China what would that process
look like well if we needed to attack
China directly of course if we needed to
deploy troops to destroy them and put
them back in their place for threatening
the master the general public would
never approve they'd go all up in arms
and protest because they would be the
ones fighting it we need to seduce them
to the idea of a modern-day war war no
easy feat we need to make them believe
that war is so inevitable so inexorable
to the enemies just waiting to attack us
that oh well what can we do we might as
well just attack so we're not sitting
ducks rarely if ever does a war just
kind of fall down from the sky the
foundation needs to be laid and the case
is built often with deception and what
better way to get the public to buy into
the bloodshed then with the time-tested
method of war propaganda just like how
we've methodically used it time and time
again in the past
the war propaganda function in the
United States is finely tuned it's
sophisticated and most of all it blends
into the media terrain while the names
of the countries changed and of course
each circumstance was different there
were some parallels that cried out for
examination to preserve freedom and
peace no one should doubt our desire for
peace the United States wants peace we
seek peace we strive for peace as
Americans we like to think that were not
subjected to propaganda from our own
government certainly that we're not
subjected to propaganda that's trying to
drag the country into war throughout
human history humans needed a way to
answer the question of how should I
conduct myself in the world to make the
most out of their lives so they use folk
tales stories misra legend books and
today movies and one thing that I stay
consistent throughout all these myths is
the eternal battle between good and evil
protagonists vs. antagonist good guy
versus bad guy and the concept of good
fighting evil is so ingrained in us it's
so primal to us that if you can activate
it in people they'll go to the ends of
the earth they'll do whatever they can
to defeat evil this is the first step in
our war propaganda machine in order to
get people to not only risk their lives
but to be proud to risk their lives
fighting for their nation they have to
believe that they are the mythological
good guys whether that's true or not and
their findings button and to those evil
barbarian bad guys states like these
constitute and axis of evil these are
barbaric people servants of evil the
cult of evil came
monumental struggle a good versus evil
but good will prevail and you do this
with some good old-fashioned character
assassination get on TV and exaggerate
their flaws find some leverage in their
history that you can exploit to make
them look evil this Mad Dog of the
Middle East I find he's not only a
barbarian but he's flaky the drug
indicted drug-related indicted dictator
of Panama don't lie but also leave out
some inconvenient truths anything that
makes them look good
a lot of people in the modern West view
Hitler as the ultimate symbol of evil so
use the time-tested method of comparing
them to Hitler President Bush calls
Saddam Hussein a little Hitler again
today we're dealing with Hitler
revisited bin Laden and his terrorist
allies have made their intentions as
clear as Landon and Hitler before them
and basically do whatever you can to
invoke as much fear hatred and
nationalism into the populace as
possible in the case of China this is
quite literally the easiest parts they
have concentration camps they harvest
people's organs they have the most
advanced spying apparatus on the planet
no freedom of speech no freedom of press
it's like China is handing you this on a
silver platter
along the same lines when people look in
the mirror they need to believe that
they're a good moral person if they
don't they'll have an identity crisis
and do whatever they can to make them
feel whole again so if people believe
that war is immoral that by going to war
they're immoral they won't be able to
look themselves in the mirror and we'll
never support it so you got to change
this perception by making war look like
the most moral altruistic thing we can
do in this situation clearly your
biggest objective is finding a path to
peace not war that you've considered all
other options that we don't use force
willy-nilly but the evil enemy has left
us with no other choices the United
States does not start fights America
does not seek conflict I don't like to
use military force our nation enters
this conflict reluctantly but most
importantly you have to frame war as a
path to peace now we need to fight to
spread democracy and freedom to these
poor people enslaved by the Chinese
government to liberate them from their
vicious dictator our cause of Liberty
our cause of freedom our cause of
compassion and understanding people want
democracy peace and the chance for a
better life in dignity and freedom we
want to lift lives around the world not
take them because if people believe that
their intentions are good that they're
fighting for something bigger than
themselves killing and being killed is
all of a sudden the most altruistic
thing you can do as you start to get the
population on the moral high ground it's
safe to start ordering some small-scale
and military action while we move on to
the next step
so you set the stage Creed the enemy in
the eyes of the public made them believe
that they're on the moral high ground
against these savages you've
transitioned the populace from what no
war what China's gonna happen anytime
soon - hmm there's a slight possibility
that we might be headed for war now we
need to gradually transition them from
the sentiment of a possibility for war -
yeah we're probably gonna go war any day
now this is where a big media comes in
people have been conditioned to believe
that the media is supposed to be
independent that this freedom of press
that they're supposed to fact-check what
people tell them so there's a primal
trust in these experts but you and I
know different see big media and the
government have a symbiotic relationship
we need media to promote our agenda and
propaganda while not reporting what we
don't want the public to know about but
media is also equally reliant on us the
government one main reason is that if
they don't play ball with us we won't
invite them to press conferences they
won't get special access we won't send
government officials onto their shows if
they don't play ball their competitors
will which will hit their bottom line
the other main reason is simple fear
fear is profitable fear sells fear gets
eyeballs clicks ad revenue what we might
be going to war honey we have to watch
this kind of like this video and where
do they go to get new fear to report on
that's right us so when you give them
new press releases to gradually escalate
to the belief that wow we're gonna go a
war any time now we're basically hitting
the money on a silver platter
they're not gonna bat an eye they're not
even gonna fact-check you in fact
they'll be begging you to get them more
propaganda to promote because more
propaganda equals more but inevitable
war is inexorable well I think that's
exactly right war is inevitable and it
is approaching inexorably so half every
press release be a little bit more
worrisome than the last one treat it
like a great suspenseful movie and big
media would take care of the rest
is war with Iraq inevitable right now I
think it's 95% inevitable you at this
point don't see any other option but war
do you I'm asking you have asthma we're
way too far out front in this
sent us over there guys let's get on
with it let's get it over with as the
drumbeat of more crescendos there's
always some pivotal moment that you can
use as a catalyst as the moment where
you can say screwless we're going to war
for world war ii it was the attack on
Pearl Harbor for Vietnam it was a gulf
of tonkin attack for Iraq it was WMDs
what will it be for China Pearl Harbor
that was a genuine catalyst
gulf of tonkin for Vietnam and WMDs for
Iraq not so much we had to use a lot of
deception a lot of Lies a lot of leaving
out inconvenient facts for those events
which is why when we did go to war
public support dramatically dropped as
the facts came out compared to World War
two where public support stayed stable
so what's the lesson from this the more
genuine in reeled the catalyst the more
support you'll maintain after the war
starts
but whatever route you take just make
sure you come off appearing absolutely
certain about the catalyst this is it
it's time to go to war give people the
leader that they need in times of
uncertainty like this sure you'll have
politicians and smaller media outlets
here and there that will question the
official story but no one takes them as
seriously as a CNN or New York Times
anyways there'll be the unpatriotic
outsiders
once the story is out boom by voting a
sense of good versus evil by making
people feel that they're on the moral
high ground and the pursuit of Peace and
Democracy justifies war and by gradually
getting that drumbeat of battle rising
we're pals in the media until that one
calais event it's finally time to go to
war with almost full support of your
clubs but you're not done yet
just because you got the war started
doesn't mean people will stay supportive
like we saw in Alaska again depending on
how truthful you've been this whole time
depending on how credible the enemy is
how well you painted them as a symbol of
evil the more support you'll maintain
with this war with China keep people's
mind off of whether or not you should be
at war in the first place by having the
media cover the war itself
particularly in the early stages news
coverage of war is much more like PR
about war if people are only seeing the
atrocities of war of course they'll stop
supporting it so control the flow of
information the best you can by only
showing off your wins to your military
might at the US military command center
in Qatar a Hollywood set designer was
brought in to create a $200,000 backdrop
for official war British reporters are
gonna want to go to the frontlines to
report but if they go on their own don't
end up reporting on a sign of getting
blocked we can't have that so let
reporters in with open arms so they're
on the side with the bombs instead make
them feel a part of the team made them
bond with the soldiers to make them feel
like a soldier because soldiers would
never betray their fellow brothers now
what they it was a gradual process of
getting to know and trust each other and
for them trusting me was knowing I would
not blow their objective and get us all
shelled with artillery of course they'll
always be anti-war the center's so shame
them into silence now how could you we
have brave men and women on the front
lines fighting for your freedom and you
can't even show them support and of
course make sure the public gets it in
their head that what drawing is
unacceptable we're not leaving so long
as I'm the president there would be a
huge mistake our allies would lose
confidence to yield to force in Vietnam
would
can that confident a sign that says
we're gonna leave before the job is done
simply embolden terrorists they retreat
a Viet from the United States from
Vietnam would be a communist victory
victory of the massive proportions and
would lead to World War three and that
ladies and gentlemen is how you get a
country to go to war theoretically of
course but here's the thing getting a
population to go to war takes a lot of
planning and coordination in the world
that's getting less and less private and
when all this is over if some pesky
journalists are able to trace your
additional puppet strings back to you
online you're gonna be screwed here's
how it works whenever you try to access
anything over the Internet you start by
connecting to your internet service
provider first thank AT&T Comcast etc
your provider then redirects you to
whatever nefarious stuff they're trying
to connect to online which means they
can see and log everything you do
they may even hand over your browsing
history to advertisers or even worse
government agencies so if you're already
willing to plan for a potential war with
China you might as well plan against
your online activities getting out to
the public this is where a VPN comes in
it routes everything you do online
through a special server it hides our IP
address and encrypts all your traffic to
make sure that no Outsiders get their
hands on your confidential data and what
noir VPN all you have to do is open the
app press Quick Connect and you're
protected and for a limited time Norden
VPN is offering you guys 70% off the
three-year plan plus an extra month of
free when you visit your new VPN or Jake
Tran and use the coupon code Jake Trend
this is the same VPN I trust when I'm
researching stuff like how the money
launder and it becomes even more
important when I'm connected to public
Wi-Fi being that my entire business my
passwords my money my files are all
online so ensure VPNs are as essential
in today's marner world as much as
something like your smartphone is
especially when you're trying to start a
word so get your 70% off plus a month
free with the link below and support the
brands that help make this channel
possible
welcome to the watch the end Club I just
got off the phone with some Chinese
officials recently and we've come to an
agreement you guys will get to increase
your social credit score when you
subscribe every time you watch a video
every time you leave a like and every
time you leave a comment so it's a very
good collaboration we have going on here
and it will benefit you guys too so get
subscribe for more video
like this every single week for free on
the most provocative stuff in the world
of business and get that social credit
score up so you don't get thrown into a
reaction camp you can follow me on
instagram IJ tranio that's gonna wrap it
up for this video you guys thank you so
much for watching you've been awesome
I've been Jake get that social credit
score up now see you guys in the next
one
[Music]